Hi, I’m Kishi Bashi
And I’m Toby.
Hope you like our music.
K and I love to play music
We had the chance to write music for Stillwater, this wonderful show.
That's so much fun.
It allows me and Toby, you know, the composers to really, to have fun with music.
And we really would hope that you would play some with us today, would that be okay?
Would you like to try?
Uhh, okay.
We brought our instruments.
Got mine!
Did you guys bring yours?
Do you guys have your bowls and spoons? Toby, what do you think? Are they ready?
Let me see… yeah they, I don’t know… oh yeah, yeah. They got them.
Okay, well let’s make music together. Toby, you ready?
I'm ready.
Okay, well let’s start with a beat. Okay so, you guys grab your bowl and spoon.
And tap along.
And it’s okay if you don’t have one, you can also just clap like me, okay?
So clap along ‘cause I’m going to start playing the violin. Ready?
Great job everybody!
One, two, three, four.
Woo, that was fun!
That sounded awesome! Great job!
Wow, you guys did amazing! You guys are all musicians here.
Now, I have a question. How did that make you feel? Um, happy? Calm? Excited? Sad?
Music can make us feel lots of things. The type of music that I really enjoy sometimes is music that just invites you to feel.
It just is this open invitation to experience something.
I was about seven years old when I started the violin. And I think I loved it so much because it’s like singing.
You know, it’s like…
*singing* na ta da… oooo.
It’s kind of like, uh, it was really beautiful to me so I’ve played it ever since.
K and I actually went to school together, so we were growing up playing music together.
Playing music with your friend is probably one of the best things you could ever do.
There’s like one thing better than making music is making music with your friends. And that’s so much fun.
Hey Toby, why don’t we play a game?
Sure, what are you, what are you thinking?
Let’s try to name a feeling and then make music to match it.
Interesting. Okay, let’s give it a try.
Alright, well let’s start with the feeling of happiness. You ready?
I’m ready. Let’s do it.
You know, Toby, why don’t you kick it off?
One, two, three, four.
I’m pretty happy.
That melody really made me happy. Toby, what makes you happy about that?
Yeah, the melody made me happy and um, the ukulele always makes me happy.
Yeah, I like, the ukulele makes me happy too
Ukulele’s such a cute little, cute little instrument. I love it.
Should we try the opposite? Sadness?
Let’s do it.
Alright, K. Sadness. Here we go.
You guys here the difference? Quite different from happiness.
It’s a little bit slower. And there’s some sad chords in there too, right?
Yeah, absolutely.
You know sometimes it’s totally fine to be sad. It’s just, that’s what we do as human beings.
If we have, if we don’t have sadness, how do we know we’re happy? Right?
Every feeling you have, um, is just important as the other. So, um, it’s okay to feel, um, any of those feelings.
I’ve got an idea for the next one. How about excitement?
I need some excitement. Good idea. Let’s try that.
That was pretty exciting. That’s…That’s how excitement should feel.
Sometimes excitement is hard because, uh, it’s really fast, so you have to kind of keep up with the music.
So you’re kind of running along with it.
That’s a big, that’s a big challenge for me.
I almost dropped my instruments sometimes, playing excitement.
I have dropped my instruments sometimes from excitement. So that’s, that’s the danger of being too excited about playing.
Yeah.
So for our last one, how about if we try calmness?
Okay, that would be a good one. Yeah, I need to calm down here.
That was a lot of fun.
I, I felt really calm.
What about the music made you feel calm?
It was like long and soft. Nothing changed very quickly. It was very slow--
Yes.
--And smooth. Yeah.
It took its time and there wasn’t a big beat. And, uh, it kind of flowed.
Uh, do you, do you hear that sound? Is that you, Toby?
It’s not me.
Wonder where it’s coming from. Maybe you guys should go take a look?
Yeah, go check it out. Let’s see what that is.
Thank you guys so much for joining us! This was great. We had a lot of fun. Bye!
Bye!